oh hi ladies meetup in San Diego and San
Diego Piper
she's incredibly outspoken does a lot of
outreach around like data and Python and
Jupiter and today she's going to be
talking about Jupiter and Prince thank
you very much I'm gonna dispel the rumor
actually I am really introverted I don't
really particularly like speaking except
for I really like the stuff that we make
so I encourage you even if you don't see
yourselves as speakers use this meetup
as a place to do lightning talks a place
to sort of try out a talk if you've ever
thought of doing a conference talk
because it's a pretty low stress place
to get started speaking so if you do
have an interest in it I highly
encourage you to do it so today I'm
going to go through some of the things
that we've been working on at Jupiter
and some of the things that are coming
down the pike I am going to do a live
demo at the end so we will see if the
gremlins curse me or not but be kind and
so as Ben said I am a core developer on
project Jupiter and I primarily work on
Jupiter hub in high-performance
computing and large-scale deployment
Jupiter hub is our project that lets
classrooms or a group of researchers
instead of everybody having to download
the notebook onto their system it
actually runs on a cluster somewhere and
then I'm very passionate about education
at all levels and I think that's some
thing that Jupiter brings to the table
as well as Python and the rich libraries
there I am also a director of the Python
Software Foundation which basically
means I help steward the language and
make sure that as he mentioned earlier
that the language is sustainable and
that we're growing
globally and then Jupiter steering
council there are 15 members of the
Jupiter community that are the
governance body for Jupiter and all its
related projects I also have some
interests in open hardware and a long
time ago I did a Cana metric modeling so
I kind of have the stats view on things
as well and I really wish we had all of
these tools and the whole Python and the
scientific stack then so what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna go through some of
the projects that we have I'm gonna
spend the bulk of my presentation at the
end doing a live demo of Jupiter lab
because I was told there was some
interest in Jupiter lab just on a show
of hands who has used a Jupiter notebook
in any way shape or form okay pretty
much probably like a good 2/3 of you how
many of you are from academia okay about
half business how many are just here
because they think coding is cool and
they just want to be here rock on okay
all right so for those of you that have
not looked or had a chance to see a
jupiter notebook we're gonna see how
well I can maneuver through my own
system if you go to try dot Jupiter and
Jupiter is spelled with a Y just to kind
of make it confusing Julia Python R is
where it sort of came from if you go to
tribe cubed or org you don't have to
install anything you can try out just by
clicking like the welcome to Python
notebook and it will spin up a notebook
server in the cloud for you and one of
the nice things about the notebook is it
lets you combine text video audio code
and visualizations so
here we have a fairly simple map plot
Lib program that will create some series
of data and then use pandas which is a
data manipulation I guess library and
Python and use that to kind of sort the
data and then we'll plot the data so if
we hit shift enter which is probably the
most confusing part we'll get lots of
warnings but then we do get a graph and
this is a pretty straightforward
application of a jupiter notebook so
you've got the and for some reason my
mouse is not okay
so shift-enter is how you would enter it
and we'll as the presentation goes on
take a look at some other additional
notebooks alright so so there is also in
addition to the jupiter notebook there's
also something called ipython and
ipython actually came out before the
notebooks
it was Fernando Perez was a grad student
and he was procrastinating on his PhD
nobody in here would have done that I'm
sure and he basically wrote this
interactive repple so read evaluation
print loop or just type a code type some
code and then the computer spits it back
to you and then you can type some more
code and it's fancy back so it's very
interactive and so that was where the
birth of the notebook started was with
ipython and then years later when Brian
Granger who I worked for at Cal Poly and
Mondragon Kelly got together and they
made this first notebook
and it's actually pretty good stuff so
where are we today
the notebook is on believe it or not a
5.0 release it's now in beta so if you
want to try out the new notebook
I Python is is chugging away through
beta for a 6.0 and then Jupiter lab is
actually really cool because the
notebook has sort of been this linear
execution of cells if you will and
Jupiter lab kind of breaks down that
linear Ness and then lets you put things
in different windows so it kind of has
more of a I need you type feel but
hopefully not as heavy weight as an ID
and it's useful for allowing you to have
multiple different graphs simultaneously
or side by side and we'll get through a
little bit more of that in a minute
but first I want to share something
called
eye PI widgets and we just had a release
of eye PI widgets and widgets really
opened the door to you know it's sliders
it's pulled downs it really opens the
door to making your notebooks
interactive it allows you to prototype
much easier if you're a student or a an
instructor your students can visualize a
three-dimensional whether it's like
derivatives or volumes or things you
could change one variable and they would
see the impact of it so you could
imagine like a high die which is a
physics dynamics library in Python you
know the the old like I've got the train
going this way and the train going that
way what happens when they collide and
you can also use that and combine it
with sin PI 2 which is a symbolic
algebra library and actually do a series
of notebooks that could actually
simulate a person's body the forces on
the different limbs and the joints and
by the end you can not only use the
symbolic algebra to do the force
equations but also use you know enter
data and then visualize a kind of a
mock-up body actually trying to mount
balance or maintain balance and again
you could use the sliders to change what
happens if the force is really strong an
upper torso or you've got very short
legs or whatever it is so it's actually
a fun way to try different things out in
science and then we also provide a
cookie cutter which allows individuals
that want to code their own widgets a
nice clean kind of template to start
from to do that so what I want to do
real quickly is and I'm sorry if I'm
gonna make you seasick going back and
forth from these things but so the
documentation for the widgets and I will
have these slides available on the PI
data repo later this evening but the
documentation itself actually goes
through the different widgets that are
already available and one of the cool
things about the documentation is you
can actually try out the widgets within
the documentation so it's not just
static which kind of gives you a sense
of how they work you know the sliders
like how do you like your eggs scrambled
so you could have different choices and
this becomes more interesting when this
is actually part of our main Jupiter org
website and in that we have a tab which
will get more widgets over time but
these are third-party library widgets
one is called IPA leaflet which lets you
do some really cool things with graphing
and mapping BQ plot
lets you do some scatter plots
and moving around colors and shapes and
there's all examples of how to install
it and do that
one of my favorites is pi 3j s which
basically you can I don't know can you
see that
like the manipulation of the the solid
and there are a number of with the
documentation there's more example
notebooks and things another really cool
project that is done by another
developer called Martin Brittles who is
not a jupiter core developer but
somebody in the community is called AI
pi volume and it is probably the coolest
thing i've played with all week so you
can do manipulations with the widgets as
well as manipulating the image itself
stereo for those of you that want to
work in stereo I'm not gonna do
fullscreen because I'm afraid like I
will blow away my screen and not be able
to get it back again like this is a
smaller scatter but it's kind of fun
because you really have some ability to
do I can't pinch alright but that's all
within its documentation so you can
actually go and I will give you the link
to their documentation and see not only
the code of how they created it but then
also have an opportunity to play around
with it and think about how it could be
used in like perhaps like a genome
structure or mechanical engineering
structure looking at something from
different angles or viewpoints okay
sorry
for the bouncing so actually where we're
going with widgets is really going
beyond static documentation to give you
interactive documentation
and not just interactive documentation
from the standpoint of this is
documentation for a library but there
are actually people authoring books
using notebooks as their platform for
collaboration and authoring and you
could actually have examples like this
in your book readily available for
people to use and run either on their
own system or on the cloud and then from
a researcher standpoint it lets you do a
lot of what-if analysis one invite the
things that I think is most powerful
about the notebook is the ability to try
something in a few lines of code and
then change it if you don't like it or
while at the same time being able to use
those notebooks to have a reproducible
workflow within science or data science
okay and then this is just a volume
which we just talked about and I
encourage you to kind of mess around
with it and see how you might use it in
your own projects okay
any questions on the basic notebooks I
Python before I kind of switch gears
yeah the question was do I have to use
the widgets in the notebooks or can I
use it in any Python codes and I would
say what you have to do is look at the
documentation but some of those widgets
can in fact be used outside of the
notebook so it does extend beyond the
notebook and into other websites things
like that so you could embed them in a
website if you wanted to do that
you're welcome okay so we're gonna do a
very quick run-through of Jupiter hub so
that I can get to the live demo and you
can see how badly I wind up manipulating
my
and computer but Jupiter hubs like I
said before it allows you to offer a
group of people notebooks without the
individuals having to install it on
their computer so at Cal Poly we teach a
data science class there and what it
allows us to do is know that every
student's gonna have whether there are
Mac or Linux or Windows that they're
gonna start from a common web-based
environment with the same dependencies
for different libraries already
pre-installed and so it lets us dive
into more the content versus
troubleshooting oh my goodness you have
the wrong version of this installed and
it doesn't work quite this way on
Windows as it does on Linux and it just
makes it so the first lecture is
impactful and meaningful and the
students by the end of the semester are
actually making some really cool
projects of their own with machine
learning or visualizations you know
pythons got a really rich library and I
believe Berkeley is offering Jupiter hub
to all their freshmen are going to wind
up having to take a data science class
because they feel as if the ability to
do simple computation on data is an
important skill much like reading
writing speaking and and I don't know
how much Michigan is using notebooks but
I was really surprised I was at
University of Illinois this past weekend
and there were about a little over a
thousand students there for a hackathon
most of them had used the notebooks a
lot of them had anaconda or Jupiter
installed which was the most that I've
seen so it's been sort of a wild ride
so the architecture is pretty much we
call it the hub and the hub really does
a couple of things it authenticates
users keeps a database of users and
administrators and then it spawns what
we call a single user notebook server
for each student or person and again you
would interact with it through the
browser and the proxy kind of is the
traffic cop between API calls versus
actual calls to an individual's notebook
server various different ways that you
can authenticate from high-performance
computing where they've got different
things down to like using Google Oh I
mean github Oh oo Thor Google OAuth
which gives a lot of flexibility to the
environments that you can use Jupiter
hub there is also a number of different
spawners some people like to spawn their
single user servers within docker
containers or use kubernetes berkeley
uses kubernetes extensively in the high
performance computing supercomputer
world there's a lot of batch processing
done so they want to give their
researchers the ability to submit batch
jobs but then also let them do
interactive stuff for when that makes
sense as well so at the end of December
we announced and introduced version 0.7
and really the big thing that this did
was it set up a services model so
Jupiter hub by its own is pretty cool
the services and the API that goes with
services lets us do other things to
interact with a hub for example perhaps
like a grading service
or sharing files potentially sharing a
notebook server between groups and
reviewer is something that we use to
render different notebooks out in the
wild and so where are we going with the
release that we're currently working on
a lot of it is being done some of it's
being done to give the end user or the
person deploying the hub different
options when it comes to a proxy right
now you're somewhat limited to what
nginx or the configurable proxy that we
had in node just that so that's there's
going to be more of that and that will
allow us to better serve multiple
servers per user so each server has what
we call language kernels so I might have
a server for work stuff I might have a
server for my particular research
project and it gives me a lot of
flexibility in terms of the different
environments that I can spin up at any
given point in time and we're also going
to get rid of right now we use some
cookies that keeps track of certain user
information or profile type stuff and
we're gonna get rid of that because it's
more of the pain so that's more let's
get rid of that so we can offer some
more interesting things and then hub
share is gonna be something which allows
us to share notebooks between users so
as a professor I could give a batch of
notebooks on a particular topic students
could pull it down we do have something
now called envy grader that lets you do
that but this will actually streamline
it and make it actually a lot more
pleasant to install in use so questions
on Jupiter hub
yes yes okay so my my binder binder is
actually really cool
it lets you actually run a notebook that
you have in a repository on github and
submit it and people can go to that site
and then interactively use those
notebooks
Jeremy Freeman who is ed Ginelli labs
was the architect of that system he has
since moved on to a different role and
so binder right now is a little bit in
flux but the Jupiter team is very much
committed to make sure that binder is
sustained so we've been in talks with
Jeremy and some others and really the
the key thing is just getting the
infrastructure people the sysadmin type
people to keep the site running 24/7 so
I don't anticipate it would go away it's
it's pretty much a complement to what
we're doing and I think it's a powerful
way to let people try your notebooks so
if there are issues using it in this
little flex time let us know because
we'd be happy to jump in because we do
have a couple people that aren't solely
dedicated to it but that are responsible
for it good question yeah Jupiter being
an open source project I know that they
have to bring certain revenue in and
there were certain topics like using
curated Jupiter or Jupiter hubs as a
service subscription service it's like a
paid subscription service
okay so project Jupiter like if you go
to Jupiter org we are a scientific
research project we get grants like from
the sloan foundation Moore Foundation
Helmsley Foundation we do have a couple
industry partners like Bloomberg
and continuum analytics who may give us
a nominal amount of money but really
more dedicate some of their developers
to the scientific ecosystem so I am paid
under a research grant as most eyes are
most of the developers are either
university people postdocs professors so
we don't actually sell a service now
that's being said there are other people
throughout the world that are selling
you know either provisioning of these
services so they're consuming open
source which is you know common in the
Linux world and other parts of
open-source so when we look at
development we look more at what's going
to benefit the researchers the
scientists the students in education
first and foremost and then if it's not
something that really falls under that
umbrella
we encourage partners or other people to
develop something as an adjunct to which
is why we try and focus more on api's
which which is like an application
programming interface that just lets
people talk to our projects easily and
and consume them so yes I don't think
they're going away the extensions tend
to more change the user interface of the
notebook itself where the widgets are
usually used more within a notebook so I
don't anticipate that either one is
gonna go away they're just going to
evolve and what we're trying to do is
make it so that third-party developers
can develop different extension
whether it's a you know an auto grading
thing or I don't know what are some of
the other extensions we have again TIF
yeah although we have a project called
NB dime that lets us do diffs and merges
of notebooks so and we're we're we've
been asking github if they'd like to put
it in their service so we'll see where
that goes but any more questions right
now about Jupiter hub okay well now we
get to the really fun and embarrassing
part
Jupiter lab is our multi windowed drag
and drop environment and it is actually
something it's in alpha right now headed
towards beta you can actually download
it install it on your computers the
installation is not bad it's one command
if you're using anaconda two commands if
you're using the pic pip package manager
so you should be able to get up and
running and if you can't please go to
the jupiter lab get her channel and one
of the developers we'd be happy to walk
you through how to install it because it
might not be you it might yes so again
that's the link to starting up jupiter
lab and now we get to the fun part
maybe the fun part alright thanks so
much for that alright so when you launch
jupiter lab you get a screen similar to
that can you guys see that or is it too
small bigger this is gonna be a
challenge because as i get bigger i lose
some of my real estate okay so okay now
this is gonna throw me off by making it
bigger so now i'm gonna make it smaller
but I encourage you afterwards I'd happy
I'd be happy to stay around a little
while and help you get it installed
that's what you want to do on your
system so you have a launcher here that
allows you to launch notebooks consoles
terminals editors a menuing system
across the top as well as menus down the
side that you could see what is running
currently the file browser there's many
different commands one of the nice
things about it is it is got
context-sensitive search so you could
just type in what you think you might
need and it'll pull up stuff that's
similar to that and then again another
way of accessing the launcher should you
have closed this initial window so let's
open a notebook and you get a pretty
familiar looking for those of you that
have used Jupiter or ipython notebooks a
pretty familiar interface that's fairly
linear and now we can really see my live
coding skills shift-enter
lets you that's a command that
matplotlib uses to render your graphs in
line and we'll just plot some random
things here one of the nice things about
it is we can if my mouse cooperates so I
can actually split the output by
grabbing it on the left hand side and
moving it there and you can imagine if
you're doing multiple runs of different
graphs you could stack them up down the
one side you can also and I pull up a
machine-learning notebook that we had
sort of pre done which manipulates some
images
what's a presentation without some cute
cats
and actually we're gonna take this cat
and I'm not an imaging expert by any
means but this person that made this
actually put some widgets in it Sigma
looks like it just fusses or D fusses it
yeah red green blue saturation of color
but what's kind of cool is again I can
grab this side of it and up here is
gonna be let's see if I can make this a
little more understandable all right so
I'm gonna get rid of the old notebook
just so we have a little more space so
this was our original notebook here with
cute little cat a cute little cat here
and can you guys see that one so we have
a mirrored output if I slide this to
fuzz the cat in the mirrored output or
in the actual notebook it will respond
which is kind of nice if you're doing
presentation teaching in front of a
class again like I could take the red
out and it gives you an ability to
synchronize the different outputs so we
can move these around we can synchronize
it I'm gonna swap if there's no
questions on this demo go ahead
shared editing of the notebooks like
real-time collaboration that will be in
the next version if you need real-time
collaboration now on a particular
notebook we would recommend sage math
cloud they do a really nice job with it
we do have post Docs that are actively
working on real
collaboration and there are some
real-time collaboration repos already up
on the Jupiter site on github but we
what we're trying to do is make it so
that you can share the notebooks first
and then we want to make sure that when
we do do collaboration we do it
well because otherwise it will be a
nightmare and a frustration to everybody
but so sage math cloud and and we do
they come to var developer meetings
online and think so what we're really
trying to do is push science forward
in general was there another question
yeah do I think Jupiter lab will ever
get integrated into Jupiter hub
absolutely yes in fact at Cal Poly for
the data science class we are the second
half of the semester going to use some
of the Jupiter lab stuff and really the
difference between going back and forth
from lab to the notebook is because it's
a web-based you have a server that's
running the kernel let's see by changing
that lab in the URL to tree it takes me
back to standard Jupiter notebook
interface that so it's actually pretty
easy to go back and forth you have to
have Jupiter lab installed obviously on
the hub but yeah so it will you'll have
your choice or both they're pretty fun
they will coexist for a while what we
will probably see
is they are two separate repos so what
we'll see is over time less development
will be focused on the notebook while
the emphasis will be on Jupiter lab but
we recognize that the notebook and I'm a
big proponent of the simple notebook
because there are some ways that it
engages students in a way that doesn't
have the cognitive overhead of multi
paneled displays so we would definitely
have a way to have the simple notebook
interface as well it's not clear to me
what the timing isn't going to be on any
of that but it's not like all of a
sudden it'll be you you'll have plenty
of notice and there's no immediate plans
to just say okay notebook goodbye it's
going to be kind of a gradual transition
and one of the nice things is it's
pretty easy to go back and forth between
the two but great question anything else
want to see more Jupiter loud no okay
yeah I will try my best
all right so okay now we'll really see
if I am worth anything here okay so
markdown is a markup language that is
commonly used in science github renders
it we can have a markdown editor within
Jupiter lab I can also open this file
not that one
as rendered markdown and what's nice
about that if I can't get it to go where
it's supposed to go
I probably should have told you I'm
actually not a front-end developer I'm
the low level networking supercomputer
stuff but you've got the rendered on the
right-hand side in the middle is the
actual code so if I actually edited this
markdown with a slight little lag you
should see it in the rendered version as
well also kind of cool if we go into the
command palette and start a console and
let me put that up there if I went down
here and let's say we wanted to take
this code and make a scatterplot I
should be able to if the demo goddess is
is cooperating be able to hit shift
enter and oh well there you go it's not
find let's run this one first and see
but it should actually run it in the
console now there it goes so you can see
it took the data that was in the
markdown file and actually I know why
that is not I need a bigger screen
that's really what I need I need my 36
inch screen that is in my office but it
basically it renders a panda's data
frame and now if we try and do the
scatter plot unless I'm mistaken there
we go and again I could pull that
scatter plot if I was okay what's
bouncing over here somebody's not happy
I get rid of this all right I think I
just might have locked up my own
computer but you can render it there you
can pull it out I'm not going
try and figure out but I assure you oh
there you go why is the dictionary okay
all right the gremlins have found me all
right let's see no and this was actually
the Jupiter hub in our face so I will
take a quick detour to something I know
so an administrator or an instructor
would see this you could see all the
different users in your class we're
working on metrics of how much memory or
storage the students are taking up we
can stop servers start servers shut down
the hub and I should have somebody else
drive and then again the students once
they log in they would see a green
button that says start my server and
this is actually on like a small
digitalocean session that I have and
it's just something yeah you know the
hardware it's gonna depend on
universities some people are using
strictly like virtual machines
cloud-based some people Cal Poly we ran
on bare metal it really depends on the
university but one of the nice things is
Microsoft has done some work with us as
well they have a notebook service in
beta right now so you could just go
there so I anticipate what will happen
is you will have everything from you
know the googles and Microsoft's of the
world that are already in the education
space
offering services to virtual machines
virtual private networks all the way to
bare metal supercomputers so it's really
gonna span but that I answer your
question yeah okay do I have an
installation job droplet with it yes and
no we this particular instance is using
some ansible scripts and I there's it's
probably in one of my repos it is not
documented but we are working on
documenting many different types of
deployment so there are there is a
reference deployment that we have right
now it just doesn't walk you through
like let's say how to do it on digital
ocean or how to do it though if you
wanted to do it on docker there's a
really good PI data London talked by one
of my colleagues min Reagan Kelly that
walks you through how to deploy Jupiter
hub so but it's coming all right back to
the hard stuff at least for me oh well
look at that while we were gone it fixed
itself go figure
alright so maybe it's just my computer I
my computer is on its last leg of its
fan and alright so I've got one more
demo and then I think you guys are
probably tired of me and probably want
to get to actually doing it yourselves
ok really
yeah ok
all right so another cool thing that you
can do is I might want to open a CSV
file and in this case it's going to show
me a table of data I can also
and in editor mode and have the raw data
and kind of put them side-by-side which
is kind of nice
you can also do it in things like geo
JSON so if I opened up turn right where
are we going
geo JSON it's trying to map that's what
it's trying to do so okay so I have some
I'm gonna get rid of the iris data and
claim a little real estate so I've got
some data about museums and somewhere
and then I can also open it as a map so
it's pretty powerful as you're doing
your analysis of your data or your
cleaning of your data you can run some
simple visualizations they'll kind of
say hey my data's making sense or no
it's really not but this was really just
to illustrate that there are different
editing modes with which you can open it
up and one of the nice things about how
Jupiter loud is architected is critias
it's sort of built like Lego bricks in
his way like each plug-in kind of has
its own functionality so there'll be
plugins that we provide with Jupiter lab
but then other individuals can make
plugins as well that you could
incorporate into your analysis and
research so it'll be both extensible as
well as very dynamic questions
ah I honestly don't know the answer to
that Ben do you know I it's is it the
only one right now I know it supports a
number of visualization libraries that
would be a great question to ask like on
the Jupiter mailing list or on a getter
Channel it's just not something I work
with on a daily basis so I don't really
know yes pull requests are welcome yes
I'm sorry I didn't hear the first part
of the question
Jupiter lab had used us a lot of
typescript yes I think it was probably
one of the things that uses phosphor j/s
which was architected and built by the
company that was founded by the person
that made numpy original originally and
what they wanted was something that was
going to be fast and optimized for large
data sets and computation and so by
typing it and using typescript there's a
little bit of a performance than not
having typed and also it lets you run
tests a little more cleanly but yeah
design decision yes they actually use
the same language kernels there's about
forty something different language
kernels there's the common ones like our
julia python that you would be familiar
with in data science there's also
Haskell Ruby I am currently working on
one some people might have heard of the
micro Python the little board Adafruit
is actually made
a circuit python that uses micro Python
but it's going to be really aimed at
education and like the K through 12
space and so I'm gonna be working on
making a language kernel for circuit
Python so that kids around the world can
make lights blink and have fun and do
cool things yeah good answer your
question multiple kernels in one
notebook yeah yes there is discussion of
that I'm you'd have to all of our
roadmap materials are actually in the
Jupiter governance repo so the roadmap I
think for the next release plus maybe
half of another release or the next
release after that is documented
I mean it's subject to change but I
personally could see a use like somebody
wanting to use R and Python and Julia in
the same notebook using Jupiter lab
you're gonna pretty easily be able to
have different kernels running with
different notebooks within a window as
far as the overall one notebook with
multiple kernels I don't know it would
be a good question to ask on the mailing
list
I don't think multiple kernels in the
same notebook they might be doing it but
they may not be doing it in the same way
yes okay
gotcha gotcha thank you for sharing that
I in general I believe that if people
clamor for it we will find a way to do
it but I can't give you a time frame
some other cool resources PI video org
takes all the PI data conferences all
the PyCon conferences I PI has all the
tutorials and talks cross-referenced by
speaker and topic and it's a great free
resource to get some of the best talks
in the Python world or science data
science world github actually has a
trending notebooks category if you do
trending notebooks google training
notebooks and github and you can see
what the popular notebooks are right now
I know tensorflow
is one I think there's some Bayesian
statistics some visualizations again try
it Jupiter org lets you just spin up
your own little temporary notebook
server and NB viewer lets you render
your notebooks so that other people can
use them and consume them and and that's
the end of what I had prepared so thank
you for being a great audience best ways
to get a hold of me is either tweet at
me or at mentioned me on github or on
the git er Channel I am horrible with
emails so I'm not even gonna give you my
email because yeah it's a sad thing any
other questions about this Python user
groups snow
I'm actually from San Diego so we don't
get much snow a lot of the repos are
we'll have like contributor friendly or
Help Wanted so that would be a good
place to start
each repo should have or link to
contributor documentation how to set up
a development environment probably the
best thing to do is if you are
interested in contributing introduce
yourself on the mailing list or the
Gitter channel and if there's a
particular project I know that there's
many issues that could be tackled on a
number of different fronts Jupiter lab
if you use it in its alpha or soon-to-be
beta state feedback is always welcome
there it just makes the project better
when it gets to the final release and
behind you is a question is there best
practices I'm gonna let these guys jump
in as well
what I tend to do is when I get a new
notebook I will look at the import
statements and see if that's if it
doesn't come with recommendations of
what should already be installed and
then if it's a new notebook that I'm not
familiar with
I will typically either create a Condit
environment or a virtual environment
using pip depending on what packages are
being used typically I will use Conda
and then Conda Forge is a community
maintained packaging repository and they
tend to have like the latest and
greatest where the regular Kondo channel
the default Conda channel has a little
more rigor
versioning testing more for like the
enterprise market so it may lie AG a
release but not radically but Conda
Forge so that would be my recommendation
for best practices not ideal one of the
things that we have started recommending
is you know that in the scientific world
at the top of your notebook to really
document what you're using in that
notebook so that it can be reproduced
and I think you could probably put some
stuff in the metadata as well okay more
questions or do you want to socialize or
raffle off the book raffle off the book
one in seven seven new people on Twitter
okay so a number between one and seven
what then you just my live coding skills
which is best worse than my live
presentation skills I'm gonna go with
three you are now the proud source tools
congratulations
I could pare it back for you
hey so next month April 13th we have a
new speaker yep Thursday April 13th we
have one of their quants from Bloomberg
coming in to talk about BQ plot which oh
cool which Carroll brought up and we
should actually be a U of M grad yeah
Applied Mathematics and I moved to the
big city to be a quanta so they he
reached out and wants to give a talk
about a PQ plot so look out for that
it's already been posted on our meetup
page just not the details yet it's
coming
and if anybody wants to give a talk in
the future please come ping us sir yes
please do not be shy I think we're
looking for I we have a lot of tool
talks I think we're looking for some
implementations of how you've used how
you've done a project or how you've done
something in your organization in your
institution in any way that you're using
Python and data together sorry are you
open to like five minute lightning talks
yeah where people can share notebooks
and kind of I know we've done that in
San Diego and it's been really fun I
think Ben and I had thrown out the idea
of having no lightning talks even
tutorials or even like maybe hacking
sessions or just a panel discussion so
we can change that up as we we see what
the community wants and really is it
goes back to the feedback tell us what
you're all thinking and also as I
mentioned earlier sponsorship for food
you work for a company we're working
with my midas at the university they're
looking to sponsor some of some of the
food for future events but uh please
help us out oh i forgot to do something
and i'll be in big trouble if I don't in
August
Jupiter Khan which is our first Jupiter
conference is going to be taking place
in New York City we would love to have
you attend we would also love to have
you submit a talk proposal and the
deadline for that is March 7th so if
you're working on cool applications that
use Jupiter in any way shape or form
that you would like to share with other
people we would love it if you would
submit those ideas okay that's uh let's
thank the speaker one more time thank
you very much
so we can probably be in the space for
maybe the next 10-15 minutes you want to
break out and do a little bit of that